quite à fait serein chicken tu es
candidat à quoi la présidentielle mais
j'ai payé moi j'étais en taule j'ai été
moi même chez les flics et 11,0
enrichissement personnel
t'as rien à aucune force à aucun soutien
on parle quand même d'occuper la même
fonction françois mitterrand où le
général de gaulle alors inévitablement
sent tout petit par au noir pour vaincre
fois que le petit promu adjudant grand
penseur il parle du poste du matin au
soir mais plus le mépris de classe
extrême droite cesse d'être extrêmes
virage à gauche
virage à droite pour monter très haut
comme ça
c'est magistral on dirait du great war
en plus raffinée que le compter sur la
clé ces règles je souhaite jamais cesag
c'est mon heure à moi mais ça sert
[ __ ] par terre la guerre sans
s'assurer qu'on a fourni 80 députés et
une grosse [ __ ] la mienne magnifique
c'est amplement suffisant pour partir la
guerre je tue durée pour gagner une
présidentielle il faut savoir sentir le
parfum du coq et c'est l'une des vitres
puis vous voyez apparaître derrière moi
le fait qu'on nous allons découvrir nos
premières estimations dans maintenant
quelques secondes voici donc les
résultats du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle damien tixier créations
originales barreaux noirs saison 3
bientôt et seulement sur canal+
[Musique]